[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces images encore proches appartiennent
à l'année passée 1963 aur avant tout
était marqué par l'écho des trois coups
de feu tirés d'une fenêtre de
Dallas instinctivement chacun s'est
senti concerné par l'assassinat du
président Kennedy mêlé à la douleur
d'une famille frappée au
[Musique]
cœur au cimetière d'Arlington la
présence des plus haut représentant de
50 Nations a traduit cette émotion
générale et souligné l'importance de la
charge qui incombait désormais au
nouveau président Lyndon
Johnson John Kennedy avait engagé le
monde sur le chemin de la détente
Est-Ouest la population de berlin- ouest
avait pu l'acclamer en même temps que
celle de Berlin Est acclamait monsieur
krutchov sans que le monde trembla 1962
avait été l'année de la crise cubaine
1963 fut celle du téléphone rouge et de
la liaison directe entre la Maison
Blanche et le
kemelin la vie internationale ne fut pas
toutefois exentete de remou il y eu le
coup d'État qui coûta la vie au général
Kassem en Irak et un mois après celui de
[Applaudissements]
Damas mais dans l'écho de cette
effervescence du Moyen-Orient on vit
l'Afrique prendre pour la première fois
à Addis Abeba conscience de son unité et
les coups de feu échangés au confin
saharien entre l'Algérie et le Maroc
n'urent pas les conséquences
désastreuses qu'on avait pu craindre à
bamaco les frères devenus ennemis pour
ind différent de frontière se
[Musique]
retrouvèrent c'est peut-être saon qui
connut les remous les plus violents le
président di et sa famille furent les
victimes d'une journée sanglante dans un
climat de nouvelle liberté les belles
saigonaises retrouvèrent les joies twist
à en perdre le
souffle à dire vrai on parla beaucoup en
1963 de la pluie et du beau temps ou
plus exactement du mauvais temps
Montmartre devenu station de sport
d'hiver les canaux gelés où des
centaines de péniches restèent bloqué
avec leur chargement de charbon
alimentèrent bien des conversations
n'allaon pas jusqu'à signaler en
île-defance le retour des loups qui se
révél être en définitif de braves chien
loup on vit la mer du Nord formé en
banquise et ne s'amusaton pas à
organiser en Hollande des rally
automobiles sur le zideré
[Musique]
gelé le monde entier grelotta le froid
bâti partout des records du Japon où
l'on n'arrivait pas à se débarrasser des
tonnes de neige à moncelé en dépit de
train spécialement frêés à cet usage aux
chutes du Niagara soudain presque
immobilisé dans un rêve de glace du plus
bel
effet à quelque chose malheur est la
mode en profita pour réinventer les
bottes et des bataillons d'élégantes et
gouttières à l'air porter à Londres le
nouveau caprice de
Paris on ne voulut pas être en restere
Manche et les troupeaux de bouton y
gagnèrent une élégance
nouvelle il reste que 1963 connu son
cortège d'image tragique le tremblement
de terre qui détruisit scopier capitale
de la Macédoine fit 2000
morts
Cuba après la Martinique après Haïti se
débattit contre l'un des plus violents
cyclones qui se soit déchaîné sur les
Caraïbes 1000 morts 100000 sans
[Musique]
abris c'est encore la catastrophe du
barrage de von qui Raya de la carte
langaron et h autres villages d'Italie
et fit 4000
[Musique]
victimes c'est enfin l'explosion du
Colisée d'Indianapolis qui termina le
spectacle
en tragédie épouvantable 62
morts des figures célèbres ont disparu
de la scène la chanteuse edit Piaf et le
même jour le poète Jean
cocto le père du cubisme le peintre
George brac l'un des pères de l'Europe
Robert
Schuman le vent de l'histoire devait
emporter aussi un grand pape l'église
perdit après 5 ans de règne Jean 2 qui
lui avait donné une impulsion nouvelle
en réunissant le concile écuménique en
reprenant en main les clés de
Saint-Pierre le cardinal Montini devenu
le pape Paul VI allait poursuivre cette
œuvre et même en décidant le voyage de
Jérusalem lui donner encore plus de
relieff en France toujours acclamé par
les foules au cours de ses voyages le
général de Gaul fit porter l'essentiel
de son effort sur les problèmes
européens et les derniers jours de
l'année lui donnèent raison en voyant
aboutir à Bruxelles l'accord agricole
qui crée l'Europe verte au terme d'un
ultime marathon qui fit
sensation le début de cette même année
avait vu la conclusion du traité
franco-allemand de coopération que
signèrent le général de Gaulle et le
chancelier ad noer dont ce fut le
dernier acte avant de céder sa place au
chancelier
era la vie anglaise quant à elle qu'on
disait s'y réservé fut bouleversé par
une certaine Miss killer ce qui entraîna
le suicide d'un ostéopathe célèbre le
docteur Ward et par la suite la
démission du Premier ministre monsieur
McMillan auquel Lord humum succéda au
gouvernement et à la tête du Parti
[Musique]
conservateur en même temps l'attaque à
la mode du Far West d'un train postal en
pleine Angleterre et en plein 20e siècle
faisait également quelques
bruit mais passons les sujets de Sa
Majesté ne manquèrent pas pour autant de
sujets de satisfaction
la visite à Londres du Roi Baudouin et
de la reine Fabiola que la reine
Élisabeth et le duc d'Édimbourg
conduisirent en carrosse à travers
Londres renoua entre les deux couronnes
les liens d'une vieille
[Musique]
amitié Bruxelles connut quelques
agitation suscité par la querelle
linguistique le rendez-vous des Belges
succéda au Rassemblement wallon et à la
marche des
Flamands plus grave fut l'explosion
raciale qui agita les États-Unis et plus
spécialement l'Alabama
[Musique]
la marche des Noirs conduisit à
Washington 200000 manifestants réclamant
l'égalité de fête entre blanc et
noir les Américains avaient eu en tout
cas une satisfaction pour la première
fois la Joconde avait traversé l'océan
pour venir leur
souris les Français naturellement blasés
se tournaient plutôt vers des célébrités
moins RAC à 18 ans François hardard
comme ch 17 devenait tê
d'affiche au jeun la devise générale
était d'être yé pour respecter les goûts
d'une jeunesse débordante qui consommait
une quantité incroyable de guitares
électriques place au jeunes on vit même
triompher dans les arènes espagnoles la
classe
[Musique]
biberon même le domaine des fusées ne
put échapper à la soif de s'affirmer de
centaines de Verner von Brown en
[Musique]
herbe 15
ans deux records de natation auprès
d'elle Michel JAAS faisait figure de
vieux il bâtit néanmoins dans l'année
les records du 1500 m et du 2
[Musique]
miles l'avenir était au jeunes et
l'Amérique se mit à faire
électroniquement le compte de la
jeunesse dès la
naissance un progrès entraînant l'autre
la roue sur laquelle nous avons vécu
quelques siècles commença même sur les
machines agricoes a cédé la place au
coussin d'air elle gagna pourtant un
autre titre de noblesse dans les usines
japonaises au profit de la
productivité le bœuf cède à la place au
pétrole qui abonde comme on sait on
réussit à en tirer un biftech au goût de
fromage aigre et la production du poulet
atteignit aux États-Unis son plus haut
degré de rendement on mangerait donc
encore demain iriton dans la lune la
conquête de l'espace aura un peu marqué
le pas malgré les 22 tours de terre de
Gordon Cooper et malgré l'accession au
titre envier de cosmonaute de la
première femme Valentina terkov
mais les fusées continuent de monter
normalement vers les étoiles et on
n'attendra plus bien longtemps le moment
de voger vers d'autres monde attendons
ce que nous réserve
[Musique]
1964 y